what are all these sneakers doing it
yeah we just now know I'd noticed it I
didn't call I did a complex show called
full-size run it's all sneaker heads and
we talked about sneakers so they wanted
me to Britt I want to shoot in here not
my house so I brought in all my favorite
sneakers so is so hard to choose so just
like they're all Nike by the way which I
really really mess with Nike yeah like
he's done a very good job collabing with
artists yeah is that what these are uh
yeah every single one of those now
collapse knows now are these all sick so
you do you describe them as sick or dope
dope dope so dope is the word you use
yes please tell me what's dope about the
purple ones they're just the purple
Jordan ones yeah oh just a different
color with tie-dye laces I would say on
that table is about close to 10 grand 10
grand probably close in shoes
yep close even if I pulled out a pistol
and just threw them into a [ __ ] box
and ran out so we got there's two of
those in the world there two of these in
the world PJ Tucker and me what what and
you had to have them because you want
fur well my boy shoe surgeon made them
they're custom made shoe surgeon now
you've worn them exactly zero times
twice what I like about you is you do
wear expensive [ __ ] you'll wear them
yeah these some people put my expensive
shoes I got beat up these are does your
most expensive yeah those are the
off-white yeah what is it what they've
cost you I don't know bring rapture no
no like two grand in a two grand I got a
matte price oh you got a right amount
just go up in value what they called the
off-white oh those are very cool yeah
these are super old school are they
you were in Seoul still fear oh I have
to plantar fasciitis because I wear so
many shoes you have to wear in Seoul
oh yeah well your your big kid those are
used for a hundred twelve hundred Jesus
Christ let's sell these [ __ ] shoes
dude this is amazing see if you go to so
the lowest the low she can get them is
1300 but if you go on to those sizes
chin click go up for our left
scroll down to sizes and then scroll
down
13 so 1,300 if you wear uh 11 a half
there 2,700
oh my shoes so many people want yep 9
1/2 2 grand
what what about 10 and 1/2 that's me 13
what oh [ __ ] I want to be cool and I
don't know I'm wearing my bare ass
throughout state you rogon sneakers I go
there just older dude they're honest
yeah we don't know if you guys have a
show where shoes don't matter have a mom
the only person that cares less about
clothing than me is Joe Rogan he just
wants like functionally he's never cared
about yeah she's never cared yeah I know
we're kung-fu jeans yeah that's some
company got him you I could I they could
cover me I can't we'll pay you 10 grand
to wear these jeans and that happening
never know now you you are you pay
attention to style it's it makes you
feel better I've never seen you not take
your threads into consideration even
when I go to the gym I dress for comfort
tell you this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]